why he's doing it is to win votes i mean
he has massively cuts infrastructure
spending over the last five years and
he's worked out if you give a couple of
billion quid hero there then you can get
pretty good headlines even if on further
inspection it turns out to be nowhere
near as generous as you did and we've
seen with this incredible sort of battle
for the um battle for the credit today
the lib dems and the tories wrestling
each other to say that they were the
ones doing the new roads but when we get
to the autumn statements um on wednesday
we're going to find not very much in the
way of economic progress we're going to
find the debt do you think this is
affordable and pedophile we've already
had the promise of tax cuts as well from
david cameron of course it's affordable
um our public debt our government's
public debt is really not a problem and
you know i'm not a great fan of george
osborne's economic strategy but the fact
is that if we didn't have a deficit of
5.6 we'd be in the position the euro
zone is in and the fact that we're doing
better than they are is precisely
because they he changed gear in 2012
reversed his policies and began to spend
now in economics everybody's spending
public and private is somebody else's
income when you cut that spending which
is what he's threatening to do in the
next term you cut people's incomes and
the cuts in spending that occurred post
2010 have led inevitably to falls in
income which hurts the chancellor
because it leads to falls in tax revenue
so are you saying the deficit running up
for the amount we're borrowing isn't a
problem it's not a problem at all i mean
it's not a problem because our private
sector is in such deep trouble that it's
not spending enough it's not investing
companies are hoarding cash they sitting
on it hoarding it because they're
nervous because they mean what for
whatever reason
and in those circumstances if government
claws back as well we will just plummet
into this condition that greece is in
fortunately we're not do you think this
is a problem of course it's a problem
it's a problem that
governments around the world are trying
to grapple with and george osborne has
tried to get the deficit down it's not
going very well originally he told us
he'd have to be borrowing 20 billion
more of the new spending this year and
now as we've just seen it's closer to 90
billion it's a massive problem and one
of his governments why does it matter if
we need the investment in the economy
well because this money has got to be
paid back by somebody i mean what you're
saying about spending being everybody's
income or debt is everybody's debt as
well and right now the households i mean
mainly children in this household are
going to be paying back these deaths we
are knowingly settling the next
generation with tens of billions of
pounds of debt and this is not just an
economic failure it's a moral failure
it's not really i mean the point is that
that that the government's debt is not
like yours or my debt the government has
something that you and i don't have
the government's cash it's called the
central bank and the central bank the
bank of england lends to the government
now at virtually negative rates of
interest basically very low rates of
interest we've seen over the period of
this government that the uh that the
interest bill has scarcely risen and
that's because interest rates are so low
so we're not going to put this burden
onto future generations because the
interest on us is going to be so low and
the income it will generate will pay for
itself what about roads in particular
are they in your view a deserving cause
well yes they are more deserving than
hs2 where the government has decided to
put his money not in that road network
but in the high-speed rail network it
has nothing the road investment we've
seen today compared to this shiny new
railway which is going to be built which
i regard to be a huge uh waste of money
we should have been spending spending a
lot more in infrastructure not just now
but also in the um you know in the labor
years that was the real chance to build
the infrastructure and instead it wasn't
taken
the trouble with the roads is that
actually we we're facing a huge
challenge which people in lima are
talking about as we speak
which is climate change we're going to
have to adapt dramatically we're going
to have to drop adapt our cities to a
new world we need bicycle lanes for
example and government needs getting to
somerset they will you know well the
point is we have to just get over this
side
traffic jams is good for the environment
isn't it it may well be but but you know
there are there are much bigger
challenges facing us in fact climate
change is a challenge unprecedented i
mean churchill before the war
warned the tory party of the threat of
nazism and they were ignored and you
know we need a churchill to come forward
again today and say that actually this
threat is greater and the investment
needed for it is greater and instead
we're fiddling around fixing roads you
know we have we have somerset threatened
with flooding we're going to have
droughts we're going to have an
agricultural sector that's going to be
damaged by all this we've got to prepare
for that and the government has to
invest to help the nation prepare
as we have to prepare for the war